This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Tim Hartford is a master at picking out the perfect little story that explains some huge economic principle. In his long-running Financial Times column called The Undercover Economist and in his books and in his radio shows, he's been my go-to guy for learning about the economics and math behind the world at large. His latest radio series for the BBC is called 50 Things That Made The Modern Economy,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。蒂姆·哈福德是一位大师，擅长挑选出那些能解释宏大经济学原理的完美小故事。在他长期连载的《金融时报》专栏“卧底经济学家”、他的著作以及广播节目中，他一直是我了解世界经济和数学背后的首选向导。他为BBC制作的最新广播系列节目名为《塑造现代经济的50件事》。
and with this project, Tim has made a podcast almost perfectly crafted to light up the pleasure centers of my nerd brain. After he produced 50 fascinating stories about 50 everyday objects, he decided to come back for another season that premiered last month with another 50 many documentaries of inventions that are so basic but so fundamental to how we live. We have three of the 50 things on our show today, Radar, which I'm sure you know about, but you have no idea how fascinating its origins actually are. The S-Bend, the crucial innovation in pipes that made indoor plumbing possible, and bricks.
通过这个项目，蒂姆制作了一档播客，几乎完美地契合了我那书呆子大脑的兴奋点。在他制作了50个关于50种日常物品的迷人故事后，他决定回归制作第二季，并于上个月首播，带来了另外50部关于那些基础却对我们生活至关重要的发明的微型纪录片。今天我们的节目中包含了这50件事中的三件：雷达，我相信你听说过它，但你绝对不知道它的起源有多么迷人；S型弯管，管道系统中使室内管道成为可能的关键创新；以及砖块。
You know what bricks are, bricks are cool. You're in for a treat. Up first, the story of Radar. In Kenya's Rift Valley, Samson Kamau sat at home, wondering when he'd be able to get back to work. He should have been in a greenhouse on the shores of Lake Nivasha as usual,
你知道什么是砖块，砖块很酷。你将大饱眼福。首先是雷达的故事。在肯尼亚的大裂谷，萨姆森·卡马乌坐在家里，纳闷自己什么时候才能回去工作。他本该像往常一样在奈瓦沙湖畔的温室里工作，
packing roses for exports to Europe. But the outbound cargo flights were grounded. Because the Icelandic volcano, A.F.Yatler-Yurkuk, had, without sparing the slightest thought for Samsung, spewed a cloud of dangerous ash into Europe's airspace. Nobody knew how long the disruption might last. Workers like Samsung feared for their jobs. airspace. Nobody knew how long the disruption might last. Workers like Samson feared for their jobs. Business owners had to throw away tons of flowers that were wilting in crates at Nairobi Airport.
打包玫瑰出口到欧洲。但出境货运航班停飞了。因为冰岛的火山艾雅法拉火山，完全没考虑萨姆森的处境，向欧洲领空喷发了一团危险的火山灰。没人知道这种中断会持续多久。像萨姆森这样的工人们担心自己的饭碗。企业主们不得不扔掉在内罗毕机场板条箱里枯萎的成吨鲜花。
As it happened, flights was yomed within a few days, but the interruption dramatically illustrated just how much of the modern economy relies on flying beyond the 10 million passengers who get on flights every day. AFYATLA YURKWIC reduced global output by nearly 5 billion dollars. You could trace the extent of our reliance on air travel to many inventions. The jet engine perhaps, or the aeroplane itself. But sometimes one invention needs another to unlock its full potential. For the aviation industry that story starts with the development of the death ray. Now wait, it starts with an attempt to develop the death ray. This was back in 1935. Officials in the British
巧合的是，航班在几天内就恢复了，但这次中断戏剧性地展示了现代经济在每天乘坐飞机的1000万乘客之外，有多么依赖航空飞行。艾雅法拉火山爆发导致全球产出减少了近50亿美元。你可以将我们对航空旅行的依赖追溯到许多发明。也许是喷气发动机，或者是飞机本身。但有时一项发明需要另一项发明来释放其全部潜力。对于航空业来说，这个故事始于对“死亡射线”的开发。等等，它始于对开发死亡射线的尝试。那是1935年。英国
Air Ministry were worried about falling behind Nazi Germany in the technological arms race. The Death Ray idea intrigued them. They'd been offering a thousand-pound prize for anyone who could zap a sheep at a hundred paces. So far nobody had claimed it, but should they fund more active research? Was it death ray even possible? Unefficiently they sounded out Robert Watson Wat of the Radio Research Station. And he posed an abstract maths question to his colleague Skip Wilkins. Suppose, just suppose, said Watson Wat to Wilkins, that you had eight points of water, one
航空部的官员们担心在技术军备竞赛中落后于纳粹德国。死亡射线的想法引起了他们的兴趣。他们曾悬赏一千英镑，奖励任何能在一百步之外击毙一只羊的人。到目前为止还没有人领奖，但他们应该资助更积极的研究吗？死亡射线真的可能实现吗？他们试探性地咨询了无线电研究站的罗伯特·沃森-瓦特。他向同事斯基普·威尔金斯提出了一个抽象的数学问题。假设，仅仅是假设，沃森-瓦特对威尔金斯说，如果你有八品脱的水，在离地面一
kilometre above the ground, and suppose that water was at 98 degreeskins, that you had eight points of water, one kilometre above the ground, and suppose that water was at 98 degrees Fahrenheit and you wanted to heat it to 105 degrees. How much radio frequency power would you require from a distance of 5 kilometres? Well skip Wilkins was no fool. He knew that eight points was the amount of blood in an adult human. 98 degrees was normal body temperature. 105 degrees was warm enough to kill you, or at least make you pass out, which if you're behind the controls of an aeroplane amounts to much the same thing. So Wilkins and Watson what understood each other, and they quickly agreed that the death ray was hopeless, it would take too much power.
公里高的地方，假设那水是98华氏度，而你想把它加热到105华氏度。你需要从5公里外提供多少射频功率？好吧，斯基普·威尔金斯可不是傻瓜。他知道八品脱是一个成年人体内的血液总量。98华氏度是正常体温。105华氏度足以杀死你，或者至少让你昏迷，如果你在驾驶飞机，这基本上是一回事。所以威尔金斯和沃森-瓦特心领神会，他们很快达成一致，认为死亡射线是没希望的，那需要太多的能量。
But they also saw an opportunity. and they quickly agreed that the death ray was hopeless. It would take too much power. But they also saw an opportunity. Clearly the ministry had some cash to spend on research. Perhaps Watson, Watten Wilkins could propose some alternative way for them to spend it. Wilkins pondered. It might be possible, he suggested, to transmit radio waves and detect from the echoes the location of oncoming aircraft long before they could be seen. Watson watched, dashed off a memo to the Air Ministry's newly formed committee for the scientific survey of air defence. Would they be interested in pursuing such an idea?
但他们也看到了一个机会。显然，部门确实有一些研究经费。也许沃森-瓦特和威尔金斯可以提出一些替代方案来使用这些资金。威尔金斯思考了一下。他建议，或许可以发射无线电波，并通过回声探测到来袭飞机的方位，远在它们被肉眼看到之前。沃森-瓦特迅速给航空部新成立的防空科学调查委员会写了一份备忘录。他们是否有兴趣追求这样一个想法？
They would indeed. What Skip Wilkins was describing became known as radio detection and ranging, and then as radar. The Germans, the Japanese, and the Americans all independently started work on it too, but by 1940 it was the Brits who'd made a spectacular breakthrough. The resident cavity magnetron,ed our transmitter far more powerful than its predecessors. Pounded by German bombers, Britain's factories would struggle to put the device into production, but America's factories could. For months, British leaders plotted to use the magnetron as a bargaining chip for American secrets in other fields. Then Winston
他们确实有兴趣。斯基普·威尔金斯所描述的内容后来被称为无线电探测与测距，即雷达。德国人、日本人和美国人也都独立开始了相关研究，但到了1940年，是英国人取得了惊人的突破。谐振腔磁控管，使我们的发射机比前代产品强大得多。在德国轰炸机的猛烈攻击下，英国的工厂难以将该设备投入生产，但美国的工厂可以。几个月来，英国领导人策划将磁控管作为交换美国其他领域机密的筹码。然后温斯顿·
Churchill took power and decided that desperate times called for desperate measures. Britain would simply tell the Americans what they had and ask for help. The Magna-Chon stunned the Americans. Their research was years off the pace. President Roosevelt approved funds for a new laboratory at MIT.
丘吉尔上台，决定非常时期需用非常手段。英国将直接告诉美国人他们拥有什么，并寻求帮助。磁控管震惊了美国人。他们的研究落后了几年。罗斯福总统批准了在麻省理工学院建立一个新实验室的资金。
Uniquely uniquely for the American War effort administered not by the military but by a civilian agency. By any measure, Rad Lab was a resounding success. It spawned 10 Nobel laureates. The radar it developed, detecting planes and submarines, helped to win the war. But urgency in times of war can quickly be lost in times of peace. It might have been obvious if you thought about it that civilian aviation needed radar, given how quickly it was expanding.
对于美国的战争努力来说，这是独一无二的，它不是由军方管理，而是由一个民用机构管理。无论从哪个角度看，辐射实验室都是巨大的成功。它催生了10位诺贝尔奖得主。它开发的雷达，用于探测飞机和潜艇，帮助赢得了战争。但战争时期的紧迫感在和平时期很快就会消失。如果你仔细想想，民用航空需要雷达应该是显而易见的，考虑到它扩张的速度。
In 1945 at the war's end, U.S. domestic airlines carried 7 million passengers. By 1955, it was 38 million, and the busy of the skies the more useful radar would be at preventing collisions. But rollout was slow and patchy. Some airports installed it, many didn't. In most airspace planes weren't tracked at all. Pilots submitted their flight plans in advance, which should in theory ensure that no two planes were going to be in the same place at the same time. But avoiding collisions ultimately came down to a four-word protocol.
1945年战争结束时，美国国内航空公司运送了700万名乘客。到1955年，这一数字达到3800万，天空越繁忙，雷达在预防碰撞方面就越有用。但推广缓慢且不均衡。一些机场安装了它，许多没有。在大多数空域，飞机根本没有被追踪。飞行员提前提交飞行计划，理论上这应该确保没有两架飞机在同一时间出现在同一地点。但避免碰撞最终归结为四个字的协议。
See and be seen. On June 30th, 1956, two passenger flights departed Los Angeles Airport, three minutes apart. One was bound for Kansas City, one for Chicago. Their planned flight paths intersected above the Grand Canyon, but at different heights. Then Thunderclouds developed. One planes kept in radio to ask permission to fly above the storm. The air traffic controller cleared him to go a thousand on top, a thousand feet above cloud cover.
“目视并被看见”。1956年6月30日，两架客机从洛杉矶机场起飞，间隔三分钟。一架飞往堪萨斯城，一架飞往芝加哥。它们计划的飞行路径在大峡谷上空交叉，但高度不同。随后雷雨云形成。一架飞机保持无线电联系，请求获准飞越风暴。空中交通管制员批准他上升到云层上方一千英尺处。
See and be seen. Nobody knows for sure what happened. Plains then had no black boxes, and there were no survivors. But just before 1031, air traffic control heard a garbled radio transmission. Hold up, hold up, we are going in. From the pattern of the wreckage, strewn for miles across the canyon floor,
没人确切知道发生了什么。当时的飞机没有黑匣子，也没有幸存者。但在10点31分之前，空中交通管制听到了一段模糊的无线电传输。“等等，等等，我们要坠毁了。”从散落在峡谷底部数英里的残骸模式来看，
the planes seemed to have approached each other at a 25 degree angle, presumably through a cloud. Investigators speculated that both pilots were distracted by trying to find gaps in the clouds, so passengers could enjoy the scenery. Accidents happen. The question is what risks we're willing to run for the economic benefits? That question's becoming pertinent again with respect to crowded skies. Many people have high hopes for unmanned aerial vehicles or drones. They're already being used for everything, from moviemaking to crop spraying.
飞机似乎是以25度的角度相互接近的，大概是在云层中。调查人员推测，两名飞行员都因为试图寻找云层缝隙让乘客欣赏风景而分心了。事故总会发生。问题是我们愿意为了经济利益承担多大的风险？随着天空变得拥挤，这个问题再次变得重要起来。许多人对无人驾驶飞行器或无人机寄予厚望。它们已经被用于从电影制作到农作物喷洒的方方面面。
Companies like Amazon expect the skies of our cities soon to be buzzing with grocery deliveries. Civil aviation authorities are grappling with what to approve. Drones have sense and avoid technology, and it's pretty good. But is it good enough? The crash over the Grand Canyon certainly concentrated mines. If technology existed to prevent things like this, shouldn't we make more effort to use it? Within two years, what's now known as The world's biggest airports now see planes taking off and landing at an average of nearly two a minute. Collisions are absurdly rare, no matter how cloudy the conditions.
像亚马逊这样的公司预计，我们城市的上空很快就会嗡嗡作响地进行杂货配送。民航当局正在努力决定批准什么。无人机有感知和避让技术，而且相当不错。但它足够好吗？大峡谷上空的坠机事件确实让人们集中了注意力。如果存在防止此类事件的技术，我们难道不应该更努力地使用它吗？两年内，现在被称为世界上最繁忙的机场，平均每分钟有近两架飞机起降。无论天气多么多云，碰撞都极其罕见。
That's thanks to many things, but it's largely thanks to radar. You're listening to my personally curated selection of stories from Tim Harford's 50 Things That Made The Modern Economy. Up next, the S-Bend. Gentility of speech is at an end. Thundered an editorial in London's city press. It stinks. The stink in question was partly metaphorical.
这归功于许多因素，但很大程度上归功于雷达。你正在收听我个人精选的蒂姆·哈福德的《塑造现代经济的50件事》中的故事。接下来是S型弯管。“言语的文雅已走到尽头。”伦敦《城市新闻》的一篇社论如雷霆般怒吼。“它太臭了。”所说的臭味部分是隐喻。
Politicians were failing to tackle an obvious problem. As its population grew, London's system for disposing of human waste became woefully inadequate. To relieve pressure on cesspit, which were prone to leaking, overflowing and belching explosive methane, the authorities had instead started encouraging sewage into gullies. However, this created a different issue. The gullies were originally intended only for rainwater, and they emptied directly into the river Thames. So that was the literal stink. The Thames became an open sewer. The distinguished scientist, Michael Faraday,
政客们未能解决一个显而易见的问题。随着人口增长，伦敦处理人类排泄物的系统变得极其不足。为了减轻容易泄漏、溢出并喷出爆炸性甲烷的粪坑的压力，当局开始鼓励将污水排入排水沟。然而，这造成了另一个问题。排水沟最初仅用于雨水，它们直接排入泰晤士河。所以那是字面意义上的臭味。泰晤士河变成了一个露天污水沟。杰出的科学家迈克尔·法拉第，
was moved by a boat journey to write to the Times newspaper. He described the river water as an opaque pale brown fluid. Near the bridges, the feculents rolled up in clouds, so dense that they were visible at the surface. Colourer was rife. One outbreak killed 14,000 Londoners, nearly one in every hundred. Civil engineer Joseph Baseljet drew up plans for new, closed sewers to pump the waste far from the city.
在一次乘船旅行后，写信给《泰晤士报》。他将河水描述为一种不透明的淡棕色液体。在桥梁附近，污物卷成云团，浓密到在水面上清晰可见。霍乱横行。一次疫情夺走了14000名伦敦人的生命，几乎每百人中就有一人死亡。土木工程师约瑟夫·巴扎尔格特制定了新的封闭式下水道计划，将废物泵送到远离城市的地方。
It was this project that politicians came under pressure to approve. politicians came under pressure to approve. Michael Faraday ended his letter by pleading with those who exercise power or have responsibility to stop neglecting the problem, lest a hot season gives a sad proof of the folly of our carelessness. And three years later, that's exactly what happened. The sweltering hot summer of 1858 made London's malodorous river impossible to politely ignore or to discuss obliquely with gentility of speech. The heat wave became popularly known as the Great Stink.
正是这个项目，政客们承受着批准的压力。迈克尔·法拉第在信的结尾恳求那些行使权力或负有责任的人停止忽视这个问题，以免炎热的季节给我们粗心大意的愚蠢行为带来悲惨的证明。三年后，事情果然如此。1858年酷热的夏天使得伦敦那恶臭的河流变得无法礼貌地忽视，也无法含蓄地讨论。这场热浪被大众称为“大恶臭”。
If you live in a city with modern sanitation, it's hard to imagine daily life being permeated with a suffocating stench of human excrement. For that, we have a number of people to thank, but perhaps none more so than the unlikely figure of Alexander coming. A watchmaker in London, a century before the Great Stink, coming one renowned for his mastery of intricate mechanics. King George III commissioned him to make an elaborate instrument for recording atmospheric pressure, and he pioneered the
如果你生活在一个拥有现代卫生设施的城市，很难想象日常生活会被人类排泄物那令人窒息的恶臭所渗透。为此，我们要感谢许多人，但也许最应该感谢的是亚历山大·卡明这个不太可能的人物。在大恶臭发生前一个世纪，伦敦的一位钟表匠，卡明以精通复杂机械而闻名。乔治三世国王委托他制作一种精密的仪器来记录大气压力，他还是
microtome, a device for cutting ultra-fine slivers of wood for microscopic analysis. But Cummings' world-changing invention owed nothing to precision engineering. It was a bit of pipe with a curve in it. In 1775, coming, patented, the S-bend. This became the missing ingredient to create the flushing toilet, and with it, public sanitation as we know it. Flushing toilets had previously founded on the problem of smell. The pipe that connects the toilet to the sewer, allowing urine and feces to be flushed away, will also let sewer odors wafth back up, unless you can create some kind of airtight seal. Coming solution was simplicity itself. Bend the pipe. Water settles in the dip, stopping smells coming up.
切片机的先驱，这是一种用于切割超薄木片以进行显微分析的设备。但卡明改变世界的发明与精密工程无关。它只是一段带弯曲的管子。1775年，卡明获得了S型弯管的专利。这成为了制造抽水马桶缺失的成分，并随之带来了我们所知的公共卫生。抽水马桶此前因气味问题而失败。连接马桶和下水道的管道，在冲走尿液和粪便的同时，也会让下水道的气味回流，除非你能制造某种气密密封。卡明的解决方案简单至极。弯曲管道。水停留在凹陷处，阻止气味上升。
Flushing the toilet replenishes the water. While we've moved on alphabetically from the S-bend to the U-bend, flushing toilets still deploy the same insight. Rollout, however, came slowly. By 1851, a lifetime after Cummings Payton, flushing toilets remain novel enough in London to cause mass excitement when introduced at the Great Exhibition in Crystal Palace. Use of the facilities cost one penny, giving the English language one of its enduring euphemisms
冲马桶会补充水分。虽然我们在字母表上从S型弯管转向了U型弯管，但抽水马桶仍然使用相同的见解。然而，推广进展缓慢。到1851年，即卡明获得专利的一代人之后，抽水马桶在伦敦仍然足够新奇，以至于在水晶宫举办的万国博览会上推出时引起了轰动。使用这些设施需要一便士，这为英语贡献了一个持久的委婉语，
for emptying one's bladder to spend a penny. If the Great Exhibition gave London as a vision of how public sanitation could be, clean and smell-free, no doubt that added to the weight of popular discontent, as politicians dragged their heels over finding the funds for Joseph Basilgette's planned sewers. We still haven't reliably managed to solve the problem of collective action, how to get those who exercise power or have responsibility as Faraday put it to organise themselves. There's been a great deal of progress. According to the World Health Organization, the proportion of the world's people who have access to what's called improved sanitation,
用来形容排尿——“花一便士”。如果万国博览会给了伦敦一个公共卫生可以是什么样子的愿景——干净且无味，那么毫无疑问，当政客们在为约瑟夫·巴扎尔格特计划的下水道筹集资金时拖拖拉拉，这增加了大众不满的压力。我们仍然没有可靠地解决集体行动的问题，即如何让法拉第所说的那些行使权力或负有责任的人组织起来。已经取得了很大进展。根据世界卫生组织的说法，世界上能够获得所谓“改善卫生设施”的人口比例，
is increased from around a quarter in 1980 to around two thirds today. That's a big step forward. But still, two and a half billion people remain without improved sanitation, and improved sanitation itself is a low bar. It hygienically separates human excreta from human contact, but it doesn't necessarily treat the sewage itself. Fewer than half the world's people have access to sanitation systems that do that. The economic costs of this ongoing failure to roll out proper sanitation are many and varied,
从1980年的约四分之一增加到今天的约三分之二。这是一个巨大的进步。但仍然有25亿人没有改善的卫生设施，而改善的卫生设施本身也是一个很低的标准。它卫生地将人类排泄物与人类接触隔离开来，但并不一定处理污水本身。世界上只有不到一半的人口能够使用能做到这一点的卫生系统。这种在推广适当卫生设施方面持续失败的经济成本是多种多样的，
from healthcare for diarrheal diseases to foregone revenue from hygiene conscious tourists. ongoing failure to roll out proper sanitation and many and varied, from health care for dioriel diseases to foregone revenue from hygiene conscious tourists. The World Bank's Economics of Sanitation Initiative has tried to tot up the price tag. Across various African countries, for example, it reckons inadequate sanitation lobs one or two percentage points off GDP. In India and Bangladesh, over 6% in Cambodia, 7%. That soon adds up. The challenge is that public sanitation isn't something the market necessarily provides.
从腹泻疾病的医疗保健到因注重卫生的游客而损失的收入。世界银行的“卫生经济学倡议”试图计算其价格标签。例如，在各个非洲国家，它估计卫生设施不足使GDP下降了1到2个百分点。在印度和孟加拉国超过6%，在柬埔寨为7%。这很快就会累积起来。挑战在于公共卫生设施并不是市场必然会提供的。
Toilets cost money but defecating in the street is free. If I install a toilet, I bear all the costs, while the benefits of the cleaner street are felt by everyone. In economic parlance, that's a positive externality, and goods which have positive externalities tend to be bought at a slower pace than society as a whole would prefer. Contrast, say, the mobile phone. That also costs money, but as long as there's somebody else I can phone, it benefits a crew largely to me. And that's one reason why, although the S-Bend has been around for 10 times as long as the mobile phone, many more people already
马桶需要花钱，但在街上排便却是免费的。如果我安装一个马桶，我承担了所有成本，而街道更清洁的好处却被每个人感受到。用经济学术语来说，这是一种正外部性，而具有正外部性的商品往往比整个社会所希望的购买速度要慢。相比之下，比如手机。它也需要花钱，但只要有别人可以让我打电话，它带来的好处主要归于我。这就是为什么尽管S型弯管存在的时间是手机的10倍，但拥有手机的人数已经远多于
own a mobile phone than a flushing toilet. If you want to buy a flushing toilet, it also helps if there's a system of sewers to plummet into, and creating that system is a major undertaking, financially and logistically. When Joseph Basiljet finally got the cash to build London sewers, they took 10 years to complete and necessitated digging up 2.5 million cubic metres of earth. Because of the externality problem, such a project might not appeal to private investors. It tends to require determined politicians, willing taxpayers and well-functioning municipal governments.
拥有抽水马桶的人数。如果你想买一个抽水马桶，如果有一个可以排入的下水道系统也会有帮助，而建立该系统在财务和后勤上都是一项重大工程。当约瑟夫·巴扎尔格特最终获得资金建造伦敦下水道时，它们花了10年时间才完成，并需要挖掘250万立方米的土方。由于外部性问题，这样的项目可能不会吸引私人投资者。它往往需要坚定的政客、愿意纳税的纳税人和运作良好的市政政府。
And those, it seems, are in short supply. London's lawmakers prevaricated. But when they finally acted acted they didn't hang about. It took just 18 days to rush through the necessary legislation for Baseljet's plans. What explains this sudden, impressive aliquity? A quirk of geography. London's parliament building is located right next to the River Thames. Officials tried to shield lawmakers from the great stink, soaking the curtains in chloride of lime in a bid to mask the stench. But it was no use. Try as they might, the politicians couldn't ignore it. The Times described, with a note of grim
而这些，似乎都很短缺。伦敦的立法者们推诿拖延。但当他们最终采取行动时，他们并没有犹豫。仅仅用了18天就匆忙通过了巴扎尔格特计划所需的立法。是什么解释了这种突然的、令人印象深刻的效率？地理上的一个怪癖。伦敦的议会大厦位于泰晤士河畔。官员们试图保护立法者免受大恶臭的侵害，用氯化石灰浸泡窗帘以试图掩盖恶臭。但没用。无论他们怎么努力，政客们都无法忽视它。《泰晤士报》带着一丝冷酷的
satisfaction, how members of Parliament had been seen abandoning the building's library. Each gentleman with a handkerchief to his nose, if only concentrating politicians' minds were always that easy. We have one more story from season two of 50 things that made the modern economy with Tim Harford. After this, you're listening to Tim Harford's 50 things that made the modern economy with Tim Harford after this. You're listening to Tim Harford's 50 things that made the modern economy on 99% invisible. I found Rome, a city of bricks,
满足感描述了议员们是如何被看到放弃大楼图书馆的。每位绅士都用手帕捂着鼻子。如果集中政客的思想总是那么容易就好了。我们还有最后一个来自蒂姆·哈福德的《塑造现代经济的50件事》第二季的故事。在此之后，你正在收听蒂姆·哈福德的《塑造现代经济的50件事》。在此之后，你正在收听《99%隐形》节目中的蒂姆·哈福德的《塑造现代经济的50件事》。我发现罗马是一座砖城，
and left it, a city of marble. That's supposed to have been the boast of Caesar Augustus, the first Roman emperor, just over 2000 years ago. If it was, he was exaggerating. Ancient Rome is a city of brick, no less glorious for that. Augustus was also joining a long tradition of denigrating or overlooking one of the most ancient and versatile of building materials. The great Roman architectural writer Vitruvius mentions them only in passing. Denis Diderot's great French encyclopedia of the sciences, arts and crafts published in 1751 and an inspiration for Adam Smith's famous description of the pin factory.
离开时它是一座大理石之城。据说这是凯撒·奥古斯都，第一位罗马皇帝，在两千多年前的吹嘘。如果是真的，他在夸大其词。古罗马是一座砖城，但这并不影响它的辉煌。奥古斯都也加入了一个贬低或忽视最古老、最多功能建筑材料之一的悠久传统。伟大的罗马建筑作家维特鲁威只是顺便提到了它们。丹尼斯·狄德罗那部伟大的法国科学、艺术和工艺百科全书于1751年出版，也是亚当·斯密对针厂著名描述的灵感来源。
Well, Diderot doesn't trouble himself to include any images of brick making at all. That's because a brick is such an intuitive thing. People have been teaching themselves to build simple structures out of brick for many thousands of years, and Grandwons too. The hanging gardens of Babylon were made of brick for many thousands of years and grand ones too. The hanging gardens of Babylon were made of brick, so was the biblical tower of Babel. Come, let's make bricks and bake them thoroughly. That's Genesis 11, verse 3. They used brick instead of stone. They used brick instead of stone. By verse 5, the Lord is on the scene, and things aren't looking too good for the brick-loving citizens of Bable.
好吧，狄德罗根本没费心去包含任何关于砖块制造的图片。这是因为砖块是一种非常直观的东西。几千年来，人们一直在自学如何用砖块建造简单的结构，而且是宏伟的结构。巴比伦的空中花园是用砖块建造的，圣经中的巴别塔也是。来，我们做砖，把它们烧透。那是《创世记》第11章第3节。他们用砖代替石头。他们用砖代替石头。到了第5节，上帝出现在现场，对于热爱砖块的巴别塔公民来说，情况看起来不太妙。
As James Campbell and Will Price point out in their magisterial history of bricks, the humble cuboid is everywhere. The biggest man-made structure on the planet, the Ming Dynasty Great Wall of China, is largely constructed of brick. The astonishing temples of Bagan and Myanmar, the Taj Mahal in India, mighty Malbork Castle in Poland, Siena's Palazzo and Florence's Duomo, the bridges of Isfahan in Iran, Hampton Court Palace in West London, all brick. So is the best church in the world, Ayasafir in Istanbul, the best bridge, Clifton suspension
正如詹姆斯·坎贝尔和威尔·普莱斯在他们那部权威的砖块历史中所指出的，这种卑微的长方体无处不在。地球上最大的人造结构，明长城，主要是用砖建造的。缅甸蒲甘令人惊叹的寺庙、印度的泰姬陵、波兰强大的马尔堡城堡、锡耶纳的市政厅和佛罗伦萨的大教堂、伊朗伊斯法罕的桥梁、伦敦西部的汉普顿宫，全都是砖造的。世界上最好的教堂，伊斯坦布尔的圣索菲亚大教堂，最好的桥梁，克利夫顿悬索
bridge in Bristol, and the best skyscraper, the Chrysler building in Manhattan. Brick, brick, brick. The architect, Frank Lloyd Wright, once posted that he could make a brick worth its weight in gold. This all started a long time ago. Bricks seemed to have been with us since the very dawn of civilization.
桥，以及最好的摩天大楼，曼哈顿的克莱斯勒大厦，也是如此。砖，砖，砖。建筑师弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特曾吹嘘说，他能让一块砖价值连城。这一切始于很久以前。砖块似乎从文明的黎明起就一直伴随着我们。
The oldest were found in Jericho, in Jordan, by the archaeologist Kathleen Kenyon in 1952. There's something between 9,600 and 10,300 years old, and a simply loaves of mud baked dry in the sun then stacked up and glued together with more mud. stacked up and glued together with more mud. The next big step forward was the simple brick mold. Also originating from Mesopotamia, at least 7,000 years old, and depicted with great clarity on a tomb painting in Thebes Egypt.
最古老的砖块是考古学家凯瑟琳·凯尼恩于1952年在约旦的杰里科发现的。它们距今约9600到10300年，仅仅是泥块在阳光下晒干，然后堆叠起来，用更多的泥浆粘合在一起。下一个重大进步是简单的砖模。它也起源于美索不达米亚，至少有7000年的历史，并在埃及底比斯的一幅墓葬壁画中被清晰地描绘出来。
The brick mold is a wooden rectangle with four sides, but no top or bottom into which clay and straw could be packed to make bricks faster and more precisely. These molds can't have been easy to make, they predate the use of metal itself, but once constructed they made mud bricks much cheaper and better. Even in a dry climate, sun-dried mud bricks do not usually last. Fired bricks are much more durable, they're stronger and waterproof. Making such bricks by heating clay and sand at a temperature of about a thousand degrees centigrade has been possible for many thousands of years, but at a price.
砖模是一个有四面但没有顶部或底部的木制矩形，可以将粘土和稻草填入其中，以更快、更精确地制造砖块。这些模具制作起来肯定不容易，它们早于金属的使用，但一旦制造出来，它们就使泥砖变得更便宜、更好。即使在干燥的气候下，晒干的泥砖通常也不持久。烧制的砖更耐用，它们更坚固且防水。通过在大约一千摄氏度的温度下加热粘土和沙子来制造这种砖，几千年来一直是可以实现的，但代价高昂。
Accounts from the third dynasty of Er, dating back just over 4,000 years, note that you could get 14,400 mud bricks for the price of a piece of silver, but only 504 fired clay bricks. An exchange rate of nearly 29 mud bricks for a single clay one. 15 hundred years later, by Babylonian times, Kyln technologist had improved, and the price of fired clay bricks had fallen to between two and five mud bricks. That's still too much for many people. Cheap and easy mud bricks are still perhaps the most popular
追溯到4000多年前的乌尔第三王朝的账目记录显示，你可以用一块银子的价格买到14400块泥砖，但只能买到504块烧制粘土砖。兑换率接近29块泥砖换一块粘土砖。1500年后，到了巴比伦时代，窑炉技术得到了改进，烧制粘土砖的价格下降到相当于2到5块泥砖。这对许多人来说仍然太贵了。廉价且容易获得的泥砖可能仍然是世界上最受欢迎的
material in the world for building houses. But as the economist's abigit-banagy and estadou flow observe, fired bricks can be an effective way for a very poor household to save. If you have a little money, buy a brick or two. Slowly, slowly, slowly, you'll have a better house. The brick is one of those old technologists like the wheel or paper that seems to be basically unimprovable. The shapes and sizes of bricks do not differ greatly wherever they are made. shapes and sizes of bricks do not differ greatly wherever they are made. That's Edward Dobson in the 14th edition of his rudimentary treaties on the manufacture of bricks and tiles. There's a simple reason for the size, it has to fit in a human hand.
建筑材料。但正如经济学家阿比吉特·班纳吉和埃丝特·迪弗洛所观察到的，烧制砖对于非常贫穷的家庭来说是一种有效的储蓄方式。如果你有一点钱，买一两块砖。慢慢地，慢慢地，慢慢地，你就会有一个更好的房子。砖块就像轮子或纸一样，是那种看起来基本上无法改进的古老技术。无论在哪里制造，砖块的形状和尺寸差异都不大。那是爱德华·多布森在《砖瓦制造基础论》第14版中所说的。尺寸有一个简单的原因，它必须适合人手。
As for the shape, building is much more straightforward if the width is half the length. That's why if you get your nose close up to some buildings that seem vibrantly distinctive to their culture, the minaret of Kalan Mosk in Uzbekistan, Hors-Monsokaslin, England, and the twin pagodas of Suzhou in China, you'll find the bricks are all much the same. It's precisely the uniformity of the brick that makes it so versatile. Many medieval buildings, such as St. Holborn's Cathedral in England, simply reused Roman bricks. Why not? Brick production still uses traditional methods in many parts of the world, but automation is gradually nosing its way in. Hydraulic shovels dig the clay, slow conveyor belts carry bricks through long tunnel kilns, four cliff trucks shift precision
至于形状，如果宽度是长度的一半，建筑会简单得多。这就是为什么如果你凑近看一些看起来对各自文化非常独特的建筑——乌兹别克斯坦卡兰清真寺的宣礼塔、英国的霍斯蒙索城堡，以及中国苏州的双塔，你会发现砖块都差不多。正是砖块的统一性使其如此多功能。许多中世纪建筑，如英国的圣奥尔本斯大教堂，只是重复使用了罗马砖。为什么不呢？砖块生产在世界许多地方仍然使用传统方法，但自动化正在逐渐介入。液压铲挖掘粘土，缓慢的传送带将砖块运送通过长隧道窑，叉车移动精密
stack pallets of bricks. All this makes the brick itself cheaper. Building sites have resisted automation. The weather and the unique demands of each site require well-trained workers. The Bricklayer has long been celebrated as a symbol of the honest dignity of skilled manual labour, and bricklaying tools have barely changed since the 17th century. But as in so many other professions, there are signs that the robots may be coming to bricklaying. A human bricklayer can lay 300 to 600 bricks a day. The designers of SAM, the semi-automated Mason, claim it can do 3000. What are the brick itself?
堆叠的砖托盘。所有这些都使砖块本身更便宜。建筑工地抵制了自动化。天气和每个工地的独特需求需要训练有素的工人。瓦工长期以来一直被誉为熟练体力劳动诚实尊严的象征，而砌砖工具自17世纪以来几乎没有改变。但正如在许多其他行业一样，有迹象表明机器人可能正在进入砌砖领域。一名人类瓦工每天可以砌300到600块砖。SAM（半自动化砌砖工）的设计者声称它可以砌3000块。砖块本身呢？
Various designs of interlocking brick, much like Lego, are catching on across the developing world. The result tends to be less strong and waterproof than bricks and water, but they're quicker and cheaper to lay. And if you have robot brick layers, why not give them bigger hands, so you can make bigger bricks? Hadrian X is a robot arm which lays gigantic bricks that no human bricklayer could wield. Maybe we shouldn't get too excited though. Sam, the semi-automated Mason, has a predecessor, the motor Mason, for which similar claims were made back in 1967. The machine spreads the mortar as evenly as a skilled man who's been half a lifetime doing it.
各种类似乐高的互锁砖设计正在发展中国家流行起来。结果往往不如砖和砂浆坚固防水，但它们铺设起来更快、更便宜。如果你有机器人瓦工，为什么不给它们更大的手，这样你就可以制造更大的砖块呢？Hadrian X是一种机器人手臂，它铺设人类瓦工无法搬动的巨大砖块。也许我们不应该太兴奋。SAM，半自动化砌砖工，有一个前身，Motor Mason，在1967年也有类似的说法。该机器铺设砂浆的均匀程度就像一个做了半辈子这项工作的熟练工人一样。
In fact, it lays bricks five to ten times faster than by the ordinary method. Perhaps the brick layer will last a little longer yet. The brick certainly will. Search for 50 things that made the modern economy in your favorite podcast app or click the link in the show notes. You can download all 50 of them right now, and just shotgun them, just go for it. Downtown, Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
事实上，它的砌砖速度比普通方法快五到十倍。也许瓦工还能再坚持一会儿。砖块肯定会。在您最喜欢的播客应用程序中搜索《塑造现代经济的50件事》，或点击节目说明中的链接。你可以现在就下载全部50集，然后一口气听完，尽管去听吧。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。
Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. Our home for the wayward, beautiful nerds of the world is 99pi.org. Radio Tepi. From PRX. Video til the end. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我，罗曼·马斯，或@节目组99PI org。我们在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有账号。我们为世界上任性、美丽的极客们提供的家园是99pi.org。Radiotopia。来自PRX。视频直到最后。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。